joining us now host of the number one
show on saturday on sunday night life
liberty levin i call him the great one
um
you know mark
there really is evil in the world
at heart you're a professor and a
historian in many ways you're one of my
best friends
and i'm looking at history repeat itself
and if it plays out the way pop
history has in the past it's not a
pretty ending
no but how about we have history repeat
itself the way it did under ronald
reagan who crushed the soviet union
economically
and did in fact supply enormous amount
of weapons all over the world
to uh the enemies of the soviet union
whether it was in angola and africa
whether it was in the middle east
whether it was uh
in afghanistan wherever the soviets were
uh reagan would put up opposition to him
and it's a funny thing it didn't create
world war three
now i'm a little concerned about the
putin wing of the republican party the
putin wing of the media and the putin
wing of the
of the democrat party biden is a
disaster he's weak he's not doing the
things that are needed
for the ukrainians to win and this is
what's bothering me why is it that the
ukrainians have to lose why is it that
the ukrainians have to have their cities
destroyed why is it that we're all
sitting and just waiting for the
russians to go in and take out kiev and
kill their president
why is that i've never seen anything
like this in my life
they want mig-29s that's what their
pilots are used to flying we and our
allies
can give them mig-29s they want some
f-16s that they've flown it's our oldest
jet but our most ubiquitous
we should give them some f-16s to fly we
don't have to be in charge of any no-fly
zone we don't have to send american
troops into ukraine and why do people
think
that this coward putin who's hiding now
in some bunker is going to use nuclear
weapons i don't get that if he was going
to use nuclear weapons he doesn't need
us to provoke them he can use nuclear
weapons tomorrow he can use whatever he
wants tomorrow but he hasn't and he's
not going to and neither is that lavrov
that
that long in the tooth uh crackpot uh
foreign secretary of his so they're not
going to use nuclear weapons first and
foremost because they don't want to die
they want power
and then what what if we do lose ukraine
we the free people the world
what he may go into poland he may go
into other countries along there what
are we going to do then then he has a
head of steam
then he brings in nato so ukraine is
critical to the american people ukraine
is critical period these people need
more javelins they need more drones they
need those fighter jets and they may be
able to stop putin now what if putin
stopped what happens to him then then he
doesn't get the empire he wants why is
it assumed he'll lash out maybe the
people there will lash out maybe lindsey
graham who i happen to agree with 100
percent is correct some general somebody
will step out and
tap him on the shoulder or tap him some
other way and move putin out of the way
i was on the on my own show sunday night
life liberty and live-in
with commander uh richard kemp of the
british forces at one point in
afghanistan he said i don't understand
this argument about putin don't take out
putin be the first time in the history
of war where we didn't try to take out
the leader of a country like that by the
way nicely to put putin over my head i
hope he doesn't stab me in the top of my
head but anyway so here's the thing
we have taken out leaders of the world
in the past we have taken out generals
in the past people have heard of
yamamoto
uh during the revolutionary war
washington gave the orders to so-called
snipers at the time to try and take out
their generals and so forth uh putin is
hiding but putin has a hit out
on uh on on the president of ukraine
he's got his wagner group
uh which is a bunch of thugs he's got
the chechnyans their hit groups are out
there have been three attempts
on zielinski so so i think what lindsey
graham has said what you've said what
i've been saying on my radio show isn't
controversial at all what's happened is
the language and the debate
has been controlled by the putin wing of
our society
this guy is an assassin he's a mass
murderer he is a plotter he's now doing
things that endanger america
and china's thrilled china wants a weak
nato china wants does you know china is
a has much more powerful military at
this point than russia does they've got
an economy that's multiple times the
size of
russia so when they hear people in our
country
uh shaking in their boots what we need
is prudence we need to be smart we need
to be wise and so forth not not rush
into a war situation but on the other
hand
uh i think the way that we're we are
creating this situation is really quite
lousy
putin is not a 10 foot tall amazon
and and then he's gonna
then joe biden is begging let's see
venezuela iran
still buying oil from russia and opec
market doesn't get any any more nuts
than this uh by the way your show last
night was phenomenal great job as always
the great one mark levin sunday nights 8
pm right here on fox